in this video we'll talk about histone
acetylation which is one type of
Chromatin modification
acetylation might lead to alteration of
the chromatin which might eventually
change the gene expression pattern so
chromatin is made up of nucleosomes and
these nucleosomes have histones and DNA
as their component
so DNA is wrapped around the nucleosome
and the accessibility of the DNA depends
on how tightly this is wrapping the
histone if it is too tight accessibility
of the DNA would be low and if it is
loose many of the protein can actually
interact with the DNA
so the histones are basic proteins which
has a conserved histone fold region and
a tail the histone tail is a site for
extensive modification there are many
modifications that can occur in the tail
like acetylation methylation
phosphorylation ubiquitinylation in this
video we'll focus on acetylation
acetylation takes place in the lysine or
Arginine residue so most commonly it
takes place in the lysine residues
now let's talk about what are the
consequence of histone acetylation
so here you can see only one segment of
the nucleosome and the Tails of the
histones are acetylated
and this acetylation is laid by the
enzyme histone acetyl transferase which
transfers the acetyl group from the
acetyl COA
now let's see what are the real
consequences
so histone and the DNA is kind of
interacting with each other via
electrostatic interaction the phosphate
group of the DNA backbone interacts with
the NH3 plus group in the lysine
and there is an electric electrostatic
attraction between them
now due to acetylation
the positive charge of the histone would
be now masked that means the interaction
would be now weaker
and thereby the DNA around the histone
would slightly loosen up that's what
happened during histone acetylation
now
what is the consequence of the DNA being
Loosely packed it becomes more
accessible to many of the proteins these
proteins can be transcription factors
chromatin remodelers which can overall
change the transcription chromatin
landscape Etc that might have long term
effect in gene transcription
now where does this particular histone
acetylation take place has deeper
meaning
for example if histone acetylation take
place at the H4 histone in the lysine 8
or 16 residue often it has been noticed
that these kind of modifications are
associated with the transcription start
side of the genes that are undergoing
active gene expression
in contrast if the
uh as if the modification happens in the
H4 lysine 5 to 12
often these kind of acetylation has been
shown to be associated with newly
synthesized H4 molecules which are ready
to be incorporated in a new nucleosome
so it's highly context dependent
now acetylated
histones are often associated with
euchromatin a region of the chromosome
which is always active in terms of gene
expression generally we don't see
heterochromatin contains acetylated
histone
also acetylated histone in specific
residues actually create a histone code
and this histone code can be read by
certain molecules it's like a barcode
scanner that you see in the supermarket
let me tell you how
so there are three important questions
that we should understand who writes the
histone code
who can read the histone code and can
this histone code be erased
so let's look at the writers the writers
of histone codes are actually histone
acetyl transferases
and the histone code can also be erased
by histone deacetylase
now these histone code can be read by
proteins which has the bromodomin bromo
domain is a specific domain that binds
to acetylated histones there are many
proteins which can bind to acetylated
histones they can even bind to
acetylated histones of two different
domains of the 3D chromating
now these acetylated uh histones
can be
recognized by proteins such as
nucleosome remodelers such as
transcription factors so these are
really important so question is what are
the proteins that might have bromodomin
they could be transcription factors
transcription activators nucleosome
remodelers and many others
so there are many acetyl transferase
complexes some of the most common ones
are the Saga complex which has gcn5 as
the active domain and
h3h2b these are the histones which gets
modified there are also pcaf complexes
p300 CBP complexes which act on
different different histone residues so
each of these complexes has their own
preferable histones which they modify
so as per summary we learned that
histone acetylation can change the
chromatin landscape by altering the DNA
histone interaction histone acetylation
is performed by histone acetyl
transferase so they are the writers
histone acetylation is erased by histone
deacetylase they are the erasers and
histone acetylation is interpreted by
bromodamine containing protein so they
are the readers
also acetylated histones are associated
with euchromatin State acetylation at
different histone residues has different
outcomes in terms of Chromatin landscape
so these are the overview of histone
acetylene